with four new exotics are decent buff to
the existing exotic weapons and
classified gear which as we all know is
not that easy to find outside of the
global events we're all looking for an
easy way to get them the new resistance
mode could be the answer
originally I started doing this because
I wanted to complete that commendation
Westside Hetrick which is to reach wave
20 in resistance on powerhouse Pier 23
and carrier but as a solo player wasn't
really making it far past wave 15 long
story short I changed over to world tier
1 and jumped into resistance to see if
this would allow me to tick that little
box under with side P accommodations
because at the end of the day it didn't
say I needed to do in will tier 5 as
expected the VCS were a lot easier to
kill unsurprisingly all of the gear that
dropped off the bosses is world tier 1
gear
aka materials however what was
surprising is that all of the resistance
caches drop items relative to your gear
score so if you look at the chance of
gaining an exotic or classified drop
from these caches which is actually
pretty good running resistance in will
tier 1 is far easier and more efficient
I actually feel like the difficulty to
reward ratio is far more balanced than a
world tier 5 world tier 5 gets quite
challenging quite quickly if you aren't
running with a well optimized team don't
think that World Tier one resistance
will be unchallenging though at Wave
2225 solo or 30 in a team you'll notice
the NPC's really start to sip it up
quite quickly the way that resistance
rewards caches is after every boss wave
that's completed you receive a
resistance cache the level or tier of
the cache you receive depends on the
wave you have just completed for example
the wave 5 boss will reward you with the
tier 1 cache wave 10 and 15 will reward
you with a tier 2 cache wave 20 and 25
will reward you with a tier 3 cache wave
30 and 35 will reward you with the tr4
cache and wave 40 and upwards will
reward you with tier 5 cache the rewards
from these caches are as follows as you
can see here the tier 2 to 5 caches have
a 23 percent chance of dropping an
exotic and have a pretty decent chance
of dropping a bonus drop containing a
classified
tear three four and five catches have a
chance to drop another classified item
with tier five having a whopping 80%
chance I ever made that as horrible luck
with RNG so that percentage probably
still isn't high enough ohm but for the
rest of us it's not unusual to have a
single cash drop in exotic and -
classified pieces when you get to the
higher waves even with an unoptimized
build a solar flare should be able to
make it to wave twenty to twenty
five-plus on world tier one with the
team of randoms you should be able to
comfortably make it over wave for tea
this runner did a couple of days ago
with random players some of which were
actually geared to that world tier and
some who obviously hadn't played
resistance before and we still made it
to level 51 in fact we probably could
have gone for another ten or twenty
levels but unfortunately I needed to log
off I haven't really optimized a build
for resistance but I've been doing quite
well using the six piece reclaimer where
the turret is my second skill I'm
rocking the Health's as my primary and a
decent bolt-action sniper as my
secondary the healing station will
helpful constant healing particularly
through the contamination waves but will
also keep you well stocked with ammo for
the later waves it would certainly help
if you had a couple of tanky DPS builds
in the team to take care of the boss
waves a solid strategy with the team is
to hold up next to a turret putting most
of your credits into it but if for some
reason you need to leave the safety of
the turret like with the laptop waves
make sure at least a couple stay behind
to protect it if it gets destroyed
you'll lose all of the credits you've
put into it if your team is pretty well
SPECT and on point this may not be the
best strategy for you as there are
crates locked behind doors that offer
more in the way of exotics and
classified items but if you're a solo
player or have a team just getting back
into the game then you should definitely
give this a go I'm hoping this doesn't
get nerfed but I fear it probably will
but I think what they should do instead
is to make will tier 5 resistance more
rewarding because considering the
difficulty it very quickly gets - it
feels a little underwhelming as far as
the loot goes anyway I hope you found
this useful if you'd like to see more
videos from me hit that subscribe button
and I'll see you in the next video
Cheers
[Music]